how excited are you to take ruin your
party out in the road excite nervous
yeah yeah I'm very excited it's I mean I
never thought I'd be a part of anything
like this
and it's not just a podcast to work
which is great yeah we manifested this
man we wanted to do this yeah it's
awesome seeing people like in person
listening to the songs and like watching
us on stage and like enjoying it
especially in your vlogs you talked
about not seeing Todd as much since
moving out of the house together and you
know he's got Jeff now too so there's a
lot going on do you think the tour will
help bring you guys back make you even
stronger you know I hope so we've been
doing the the rehearsals as well so
whenever you know I get a chance I bring
Todd into the rehearsals and we get to
hang out there but then he goes right
back to hanging out with Jeff Koons Ain
and David so I mean it's actually Jeff
said and I saw I saw some respectably
sorry no Scott just he's busy and he's
very successful and he's doing a bunch
of different things and stuff so me on
the other hand I'm just you know going
on hikes you have some more free time I
kind of give us a little bit of hint
what we're gonna see from you two on
tour together a mix of 21 pilots and
Broadway and rap and everything like
it's a whole show it's not just like an
mp3 track in us on stage rapping or
talking it's it's a full band and it's
very it's very in-depth yeah put a lot
into it although the band mates are very
musically gifted and smart just talented
me now I'm over in the corner my piano
my holy crap these guys are amazing and
they third such a good backup and
everything like they're helping Scott
out and helping me out and everything so
we're learning a lot so it's cool
they're dancing playing guitar playing
bass playing drums drummers not really
dancing this Jennifer and Todd when you
leave the piano will you be doing any
dancing as well or just kind of stick
into the second to piano
yeah so I'll be trying to stick back
there as much I gotta hide
but there are moments where I'm able to
come out come out front and kind of like
you know party and you know I guess the
hype man part term is correct for you
know Scott to have this back right there
and you know slap some hands have you
booked the rest of the vlog squad to
come out and see a couple of the shows
at all yet we have talked to them all
and tried to figure out what dates they
can come to and everyone in our group
likes to plan things very last minute so
I'm sure if David decides to come out
it'll be like the day of like I gotta
fly out like he'll come up like the
second you go on stage will show up with
I'm actually surprised he didn't try to
sneak into it I was kind of hoping it
would happen that would be actually a
good 50 bucks a show I came home after
going out a night out and I was brushing
my teeth and he popped out of the
bathroom shot me in the leg when you
look and see everything that's going on
now for yourselves and this the whole
group in general what do you think
what's been like the wildest part of
seeing everyone's careers basically glow
up oh I don't know I can't tell like
where everyone's going you bet I think
everyone's like we're all obviously like
also friends but at the same time
everyone's like kind of like doing their
own route and doing their own thing like
it's crazy to me to see that I hear I'm
certain people watching David's videos
and everyone just like loves like just
gravitates towards David and obviously
he's a great guy he's one of our best
friends which makes sense but it's just
like still crazy to see now that like I
said everyone's kind of doing different
things and everyone's super busy all the
time
what's it like when you guys do you find
time they all got to get together and
catch up and just hang there's a kind of
feel like just being back in that house
together hung out since I moved out of
the last house that we lived in it
hasn't felt the same level of like oh I
belong here like sometimes I'll go and
hang out with people when I have a free
moment and I'm like well it's kind of
weird like it's like there's slightly
like there's a couple different people
and it's like at a different location
and I don't live there anymore so I'm
like I can't just walk away to my room
when I'm getting tired of people talking
anymore it is really interesting Scott
like I said we've been really trying to
get you in those
more and now the crazy thing is David
just keeps adding other people more and
more is there someone you've seen in the
vlogs get like added inducted into the
larks one thing with why are more people
coming in and I am NOT getting more
screen time I mean I don't really know
what to say I texted David I missed you
last night and you didn't text me back I
know I know he was awake posted on his
Instagram story at 6:30 in the morning
say that he posted so he must have been
busy editing something like that were
you talking to him I mean there are
people in the vlogs all the time that
have replaced me yeah I'm sure you guys
have group chats with me Jeff replaced
me it's not really replacement it's just
like people that come and yeah I'm ago
and they're available to film and stuff
like that and I have been really busy
lately so it's gonna be a core group
with us
[Laughter]
[Music]